hello Cynthia does God
on November 3rd we need to stop ah so
good eg other team
mookee
well curry
no tape on there
to get off this planet
we're November 3rd this film is not yet
rated revenge's revenge us I mean we
don't have to have a name to get tickets
now in theatres November 3rd hello I'm
Chris Hemsworth I'm so excited about my
new film from Marvel Studios or Ragnarok
so much happens in this movie it's
well I mean I could tell you about it
but it's gonna be a much better
experience if you buy a ticket so get
your tickets now for for Ragnarok and
see you all very soon
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is what you
become for its main event
miss this I'm putting together team
yeah Cody revenge's revenge us you know
I mean we don't have to have a name we
could have no name get tickets now I won
these leaks in sound right
the goddesses invaded us God
I'm going to stop a loan no put together
team
he's a fighter
surprise
ragnarok his film contains scenes and
language that may be inappropriate for
younger Butte
you